okay thank you very much
and uh welcome everyone to this webinar
um i hope that everyone uh found
all of the details necessary for today's
session
and what i will do in my part of the
presentation is speak a little bit about
why we are doing what we are doing then
what is the research fellowship program
all about
and how you will be able to benefit from
different resources that we have
prepared for this program
and how you can gain access to the
resources that we will discuss
so again uh thank you so much for
the introduction i'll briefly go over
some of the similar things that sonica
already mentioned but i want to specify
why we are doing what we are doing first
and talk about
how the team members that we have in our
team
will be able to help you develop
research projects over the summer
so the background of our company is that
we started as the technology
transfer company started from this
bioinformatics research center
that is focused on developing of novel
algorithms to process
and integrate multi-omics data and so
what our team does
is leverages the same tools and develops
training
resources to support research projects
and apply the different methods that are
being developed at the center
as well as the other methods that are
being tested and benchmarked
to a variety of different biomedical
research projects
and one of our main goals as a company
is to democratize bioinformatics and so
we've been working with
many different companies universities
organizations
and non-profit organizations as well as
for-profit organizations
and the goal is really to make
bioinformatics more accessible because
what we have discovered is that
many students as well as faculty and
researchers coming from a life science
background
do not have enough resources and
training to translate
research questions into data science
problem statements and
into a bioinformatics workflow and so
what we've been doing
with a number of these partners is
developing examples
and case studies around different types
of data
and different types of challenges that
arise
with that data so that students and
faculty can effectively address those
using bioinformatics tools and so that's
how
this onyx logic bioinformatics training
curriculum was born we essentially
developed it
addressing this need of growing amounts
of data
and limited opportunities for
people around the world to be able to
easily access
that data using relevant tools and so we
developed the
regional offices with an office in india
that
serves many different universities there
starting in january 2019
we've conducted many different uh online
and in person workshops and programs
we also recently established a
an office in africa where we have a
regional
team based out of nigeria so
i see many of you here have joined us
from
africa so welcome to all of you as well
there we are growing the impact of the
program by
offering these programs together with
our collaborators and analyzing the data
to be
addressing the different types of needs
that are unique to this region
and developing projects that are
relevant
to people in africa as well and of
course
in the us we have the privilege of
working with a number of
partners including one of our main
collaborations with the louisiana
biomedical research network
as well as georgetown university where
we have
programs for students that apply for
biomedical research projects and for
medical studies as well and so as a
result of these collaborations
we've seen a number of students
and faculty work together on impactful
and translational projects
and so we're excited to bring this
opportunity to you
all online as well and so what we are
doing with this curriculum and with the
support elements that i will discuss
here briefly
we are trying to enable teams of
students
and independent students to develop
impactful
and competitive research projects
leveraging
big data sets mentorships and
expert feedback so that those projects
are more competitive
and so the way that this process starts
is really
from training and so before we jump into
the research part
of this program i want to briefly
mention
what this training is all about uh
so monika do we have the poll ready
uh yes india we have it ready okay
so before we go on i wanted to make sure
that
we know who is present in this uh
session today and so uh we told you a
little bit about
our team uh so nika please launch the
poll
um if you could please take a few
moments of your time
and answer some of these questions that
will be popping up on the screen in just
a second
okay so um okay can we launch the poll
so my first question is what is your
educational background
please let us understand uh from which
educational background you are
and then my second question is what are
your research in trust
it would be great if we could let if we
could know what your research interests
are
either it is oncology omics data science
biomedical science machine learning
virology
r and python programming
agribioinformatics precision medicine
or neuroscience
you can take a minute i will be ending
the poll in the minute
thank you
okay so um can everybody
see the poll
okay great
all right perfect so if you could please
answer those
uh questions we'll just give another
minute for everybody to be able to
answer
and so what we're looking for is to
really get to know you
and understand better what are
your interests what is your background
and also try to adapt uh this program to
the needs
of those that are present today we also
have this webinar um available
as a recording after the session is over
so
for everyone that is watching this on
youtube
i think it's streaming live there as
well
we don't have a poll available on
youtube but you can definitely
answer your questions in the chat we're
monitoring the chat and so we'll be
collecting your feedback there as well
okay let's give it just another 30
seconds
and uh maybe somalia you can let me know
when
uh people have completed that
okay sure again
thank you all for your responses uh
those who are left
please fill in their responses thank you
okay so again thank you for the
responses maybe we can keep it on just
for a few more seconds but um let me
tell you briefly
what is the objective
of the first stage of this program so as
was mentioned
we're talking here about the research
fellowship we'll get to the research
part
later but first let me explain how the
basic training works
so we have a an online portal
that is called onyx logic so
you can all take a look at the pla
at the portal right now it's
learn.omixlogic.com
and what this portal offers
is a uh series of
coursework okay so that's the link
on the basics of bioinformatics so
anyone
that is present here today that just has
some
basic understanding of bioinformatics or
even with very limited
understanding of bioinformatics what it
is and how it applies to different
biomedical research
challenges we offer a basic introduction
to bioinformatics we
have different omics specific types of
training like
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
and epigenomics
and then there is an extensive
curriculum on data science that includes
data exploration data analysis
visualization and machine learning
so please explore the different courses
again in malika maybe you could post a
few
links there so people can take a look
now
on top of this asynchronous type of
coursework we also offer an
in-depth and expert guided
training and so as an example
we have these programs that are called
omics logic transcriptomics omix logic
data science
so we have a number of programs that are
designed around the specific
challenges associated with these types
of data
as well as specialization tracks and
those specialization tracks include
oncology infectious diseases
agriculture and others and so as a
result
this portal offers a complete road map
for bioinformatics and we go from
finding data sets to knowing how to
explore and visualize the data to
understand the problem statement and
what they represent
to read through research articles and
understand the research methods
as well as to gain biological and
translational insights and understanding
of what is the
impact of this particular method study
data set and so that type of training
really introduces you
into a bioinformatics roadmap from where
you can then choose to specialize in
specific domains so the onyx logic
bioinformatics training
is a topics and specialized program
for different types of research
challenges and those include challenges
and infectious diseases like
coven uh challenges in genomic medicine
like personalized treatment of uh cancer
metagenomics how to explore the
microbiome and the impact of microbiome
on different aspects of in
of disease and health precision oncology
data science and neuroscience so to
really explain
how this works i want to just briefly
show you
what kinds of materials you will gain
access
by joining this program and also by just
registering for free
even if you're not registered for the
research fellowship or one of these
programs i just want to make sure that
you understand how these resource
resources could be used so they include
training materials that you can learn
from
data analysis tools that include big
data
analysis tools because not always can
you
analyze data on your laptop you really
need this infrastructure to support your
big data analysis needs
training in coding where you can try
different types of
r packages and python as well as an
introduction to different project data
sets
so you can really explore a variety of
case studies of how this applies
so let's take a look
i'm gonna go to um
to the browser and please uh join me
as well so
learn on mixlogic.com
and please do let me know if you're
already registered
maybe you could put yes or no
in the chat box if you're registered all
right
excellent thank you so as you're on
this home screen if you're already in
the system you will see your email
address come up right here
so for those of you that are not yet
registered this is free registration so
really
no obligation this is just to explore
but you can see
here how some of these resources are
organized
and they are specific to different
types of uh applications oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience
agriculture
and what's important is that they offer
once you register
once you've created that first
registration you
automatically get access to our big data
analysis
platform now this big data analysis
platform
is a complete separate beast so to say
right it's got a lot of resources that
you can leverage
which are explained in some of the
coursework that you can gain access to
so let's take a look at what this big
data analysis platform
allows us to do now you will if you're
registered
on the learn portal you can use the same
registration
to see what this big data analysis
platform is all about
because you will have a demo account
okay so this is the link to this
platform
it is server.tbio.info
okay please let me know once you're here
okay so again login use the same login
same email and password that you created
there
you should be able to register here and
we'll take a look at just one example
so here we have different types of
honest data
types next generation sequencing data
mass spec
structural biology as well as data
integration modeling
so some of you might be already familiar
with this right one of the biggest
challenges that
so many data sets are available but they
contain thousands of samples
gigabytes of data you have to download
them on your computer
most of the time you can't even do
anything with them because they just
require
terabytes of space and so this is a
cloud-based platform that allows you to
eliminate that challenge you can just
simply go online upload your data
directly from ncbi
or from an ftp link and process that
data and so that's one of the
amazing things that are available on
this platform so let's take a look at
one example
here we have a demo of how this platform
works so
you first of all start by selecting one
of the demos
you have a brief explanation of
what the basic steps are so this is the
logic
behind this type of omics data
processing
you can see that you do pre-processing
mapping on the reference genome
and then quantification of expression
level so how many of you here are
familiar with
rna-seq
is anyone here familiar okay so i
see connect valley okay lee
all right great so all right great so
you will probably already recognize
many of the steps that are mentioned
here
and what you can do is not worry about
the organization of these steps in a
logical workflow because the system
is guided by artificial intelligence to
suggest
the right type of next step based on the
data type
and your objective okay so if you are
just
coming from a theoretical background you
kind of know what is going on but you
don't know how practically it works
this is exactly what you can use so
remember the first step was
pre-processing so we'll select
trumatic which is designed to trim the
reeds
and clean up our source data then we can
eliminate the bridge amplification
because sequencing includes pcr
amplification that is
a little bit biased towards some
sequences
and higher expressed genes then we can
choose between
a number of different methods for
mapping on the full genome or the
transcriptome so we'll just choose a
quicker version
mapping on the transcriptome
and then preparing that table of
expression that we will be able to use
downstream analysis tools to annotate
explore analyze and ultimately interpret
so
here we have the rsm expression table
once we have built our pipeline just
click on end
and now you can see the output data and
so
very quickly you can go from
understanding the project
to then being able to explore the data
that is already processed and so now
this data
is something that you can download onto
your computer or even better
i will show you how you can process it
using some of the data exploration tools
that we have
on the onyx omixlogic learn
platform okay so let's go back to
the learn portal
and i'll show you the next example so
here we built
our table of expression right so in
the table of expression we prepared a
full table
of gene expression for something like
tens of samples okay so here
if you can search r
and we're going to go into this
introduction to data science
in r okay because the next step after
you've prepared your data
now you can load the data visualize it
perform different types of statistical
analysis
explore your data with dimensionality
reduction uh
perform differential gene expression and
use all kinds of downstream methods so
here i'll just show you a brief example
of how this would work
again this is for those that created a
free account you should be able to
access
most of these courses and what we'll do
is we'll go right here
into dimensionality reduction because
one of the
bigger challenges is that we have so
many dimensions
so here you can see we've got our genes
they have expression levels
we have samples right and then each
sample belongs to different
type of data so this is taken from a
breast cancer
example project and as you complete the
introduction
you then have this video that explains
what the code is all about
explains the syntax of the code so you
understand
how to load the data and prepare your
principal component analysis object
which later on you can visualize
because r is a object oriented
object oriented language and then how
can you
improve your visualization using that
object
so that you understand the biological
meaning behind the complexity of this
gene expression data set
now importantly you can actually
practice this
right here in the browser so again you
have this explanation
but you also have these uh blocks
of code okay and
this code actually comes with a
challenge
okay so for example you can't just run
this code
but you can go to a basic plot right so
here i'm going to just run the code
that's already available
okay and i get some basic
outputs so the basic outputs include
some basic plots
but once i want to start changing them
you can see that i
have to modify the code for it to work
okay why the reason is because i need to
start
reading through the syntax and
identifying
the specific types of steps that i need
to
make so that this code works so let's
briefly
do this together you can see right table
i have it right here i need to create a
table so i'm just going to copy this
from right here
and i have
making the plot from the previous step
so how do we actually make the plot
from the previous step okay right here
we need to make the plot from the
previous step so by
looking through the code and
understanding the code
i can actually make this code work okay
what
didn't work here to make sure that all
the syntax
is true this
okay the reason is i don't have
and file okay
okay and so now i made this code work
i have this code right here and i have
created
a table of expression okay and so
now i can analyze the table of
expression
in a transform format so i know what it
means
okay so because
this process is something that we've
tested
on thousands of users we have developed
a whole system that goes from this
kind of basic training all the way
into a project that you can now
analyze in the context of a biological
problem and so these include examples
from taken from literature where we
actually go through
examples in research papers with the
associated data set
and you can find different examples on
ebola
on covet 19 on precision medicine in
oncology
and many other different types of
examples so
in every case you will get an
introduction
based on some kind of a data set that is
explained
in a publication you get different types
of methods being explained and then some
challenges that you can try and go
through
by yourself now in many cases we try to
break down
every step so that it's very clear what
the logic is behind the analysis
and not get bogged down by the technical
details
so eliminating the need for
comprehensive technical training before
you can actually
start a project of your own and so
what's important is that
we have this platform that allows
big data processing different types of
statistical methods
regression and factor analysis machine
learning
multiomics integration and biological
interpretation
as a result as we mentioned now
we are going to talk about this
fellowship so
who is the fellowship for
the fellowship is for those that have
completed the basic training
they already understand how
bioinformatics is used
and now they can apply what they have
learned
to a project of their own so how many of
you here
have come to this webinar to learn about
how to join the research fellowship
all right great okay so
the research fellowship is specifically
for those that are going to be able to
leverage some of the examples data sets
learn about different challenges that
are presented in these projects
these challenges are going to be
associated with different domains
as we already described and you can see
some of the examples on the screen that
we have already prepared
and once you are ready and you have
selected a topic
you can now apply the same principles
to a project of your own
and so you can either join the training
and i will pass it on to dr mohit
mizunder after my
part of the presentation so that he can
explain what kinds of programs are going
to be coming up that you can gain
access to expert guided training to
asynchronous coursework
and the research support that we offer
but for those of you that
are done with your training and have
already completed your basic training
now you can go for an independent
project and so that's where this
omixlogic research fellowship comes in
so let me briefly tell you what is
the research fellowship and how does it
actually work
so the research fellowship is organized
into
three different parts first we have an
introduction
so that you can review and refresh
your understanding of different types of
bioinformatics methods
but it's going to be brief the important
thing is that as a part of this program
you will gain access to a variety of
programs that we have
going on during the summer so that you
can get that training
next there's a process of evaluating
the proposal the project proposal i'll
talk about
how challenging and how to address that
challenge
of selecting a good topic and finding a
good data set
so during that time once you have
the evaluation step you're really
working on developing a research
proposal
uh to also understand the experimental
design of how the data
was prepared and the making sure that
the question that you have
is actually uh competitive
and important and significant and you
will
end up with an impactful project at the
end right so it's
refinement of that research question
that you have
and then you have also practical aspects
so that you actually conduct
the different research analysis methods
you apply them to your data you find the
insights through identifying specific
patterns in the data and then you have
to go for biological interpretation
so in this process
you will have weekly progress reports
that you have to submit
to your mentor you have a slack channel
where you can interact with the
mentor experts as well as additional
people that are going to be present
okay and those of you that feel that you
need training we will talk about
training here in a few minutes
but for the research fellowship once you
join we will actually go through this
process
with the weekly review and you will hear
today from some of our
research fellows on how they went
through this process as well
so the first step obviously is to
collect data
right and so we will introduce you uh
to different data sources where you can
find
big data on almost any topic so
many of you are probably familiar with
ncbi ncbi
has millions of data sets that you can
find
on a huge variety of topics and so for
example
uh many research data sets are available
on source code too right literally every
paper that comes out has an associated
data set
that anyone can go in and explore
and so what we just did with that pca
for cell lines
you can just take a data set from geo
download it
or even directly use it from ncbi and
see some patterns for example here
we have some pattern of separation based
on gene expression
between uh ace2 overexpression in
patients with asthma
and with covet 19 so you can see the
difference
between those two conditions and so the
obvious
challenge when you are faced with
millions of data sets that you could
potentially
access is how to choose that specific
topic for your project
and so here we will provide you with
some training
so that you understand how to select an
impactful topic
how to select a topic that is reasonable
and also how to make sure that that
topic has
significant data that you can analyze
during your research fellowship
then you will go through a process of
literature reviews
you will get to review articles that are
either primary research articles review
articles systematic review articles
and you'll get to explore different
types of problem statements
questions and data sets that experts
have already gone through and the
important part
is that you will be able to define
from a very general problem statement
like i want to
apply my bioinformatics skills to
infectious diseases to select a very
specific
hypothesis or a question based on your
literature review
identifying gaps and unanswered
questions
and then defining your own question and
hypothesis so as a result you will
end up with a very competitive project
proposal that you can actually
start working on and so then
you will develop comprehensions
comprehension
and analysis skills by going through
these research articles understanding
the methodology
you will be able to investigate the
problem
in depth and understand what challenges
are there
and then we will go to actually writing
editing and preparing
the project for submission and so what
we've done on our side
and you will uh see this uh from some of
our research
uh fellows that will present today how
this step-by-step process actually
enables you to come out
with a project that leverages big data
applies advanced and sophisticated
methods
and then comes out as a research study
that you can present and share with
others
so once your data set is ready and you
define your question you will
process your data and so as i showed you
there's this training that will allow
you to leverage these
big data analysis tools and identify
signal
you will be able to leverage different
types
of scripting methods and analysis
methods to
define what that pattern is that you
want to focus on
perform in-depth analysis in a variety
of applications
from gene expression data to drug
resistance and structural biology data
population genetics and others
biological interpretation like pathway
analysis and others
and then start working on completing
that project and so
what could be the outcome of the
research fellowship
so first of all we follow the same
process that you would follow
if you were preparing a research
poster presentation so as you probably
know
many students start with a research
poster
to develop their project and get some
feedback and so
this program the research fellowship
will provide you with these guaranteed
outcomes that depending on the effort
that you put in and the timing that you
have
you will be able to achieve and so some
of these could be
just understanding the challenges
associated with bioinformatics so if
you're a student
and you want to understand whether this
is for you
you might want to go through some of the
course work
understand the challenges complete some
of the projects that we offer
and that will give you a clear
perspective on whether bioinformatics is
for you
or how could you use it in your domain
another outcome is that you will get
training and develop those skills and so
once you've tried it on one project
you can then continue working on other
projects and apply the same skills and
the training that you've gotten
so that you can actually understand how
this is
applied in a variety of different areas
then you can work on an independent or
a group research project and so that's
where this three month
or six month training converts into a
research fellowship
that you can actually work on a project
either independently or we can match you
with some similar people
that could be interested in working
together okay
so you will fill out your profile we'll
see how you do in training
you'll submit some of the research
progress that you're making
and then we'll be able to pair you with
some others and then
finally what we definitely see majority
of the people
uh going for is to complete a poster
presentation
or develop a full uh uh
full research publication so at this
point
i want to invite a couple of our
research fellows
that are going to share just a few words
about
their experience in the research
fellowship so that you can see
what they went through and how this
process developed for
them so sonalika if you could please
um make sure that they are ready to
share um their slides
and um as we're waiting for them to
share this i want to ask and address
some of the questions that are in the
chat
okay so let's go through these questions
and someone could please let me know
when
the next research fellow is ready
okay so is it possible to go for three
or six months yes we will address the
questions of registration just a little
bit
um what is the pricing we will go
through the pricing again in a little
bit we also have some
uh we also have so so there's not really
a price to the research project itself
there is a whole program that you can
register for and that
gives you access to the mentorship gives
you the access to
the uh experts that will provide you
with feedback on your project
and also gives you access to the
training and the big data analysis tools
okay so uh just so that everybody can
see
how to actually register i'm going to
just
share a link here real quick so if you
go
to the top right here and you click on
research
okay right here this is where you
complete
the registration okay so if you're
interested
in the fellowship program this is where
you go
this is where you complete the
registration if you have questions about
pricing
this is the pricing you can switch
between three and six months
and then you'll be able to choose which
option is best for you
if you're interested in a scholarship
and you come from
a low-income country or you have a
special need
there's also a scholarship
process that we have that you can use to
apply for a scholarship we only will
give
a number of scholarships so the earlier
you apply
the better